hey Vsauce how are you doing
happy Wednesday we have a special treat
for you today because Mario turned 25
years old last week and I have a
confession to make because of my
troubled childhood I didn't get to learn
enough about Mario but I've got a
special guest here Andre
aka black nerd comedy anyway let me give
him a call
uh-oh what oh sorry I was not looking at
pictures of Kim Kardashian's butt where
we go oh I used to have a dream
Compassion's bottom is my desktop on my
laptop that I would bring in to work I
don't even know why I thought that was a
good idea as we all know Mario turned 25
years old last week so a milestone it's
a quarter of a century of Mario and you
are one of the preeminent Mario fans you
are a Mario historian a Mario lore
expert but yet on this occasion of the
25th birthday you've got some
constructive criticisms for him some
lessons learned just a little bit it's a
little bit this my Turkish ISM as he
gets older it's time for him to say all
right that I did make some mistakes and
I want to take make sure that this
doesn't happen for the next 25 years
that's why I'm here for for that first
off the bat this is one of the first
times that we've had a Mario game with
no Luigi and people freaked out they
were like where where's Luigi at people
were making fake Luigi video screens on
the computer it was like people wanted
Luigi so bad we just weren't used to not
having the Super Mario Brothers to
Fedder Luigi's a plumber he may have
been like Mario I hear you got a new
game will be there sometime between 8
a.m. and 3 p.m. and I just never showed
in addition to not having Luigi this is
also the first game where Princess
Toadstool is referred to as Princess
Peach now apparently she's been Princess
Peach for a long time in Japan but we
have just known her as Princess
Toadstool and there's all of a sudden
her name is peach it was never explained
that she officially get a name change is
she Princess Peach toadstool is like her
full name um you know it's just I
understand later why they had to do it
for games to make them short but it's
like I like Princess Toadstool it sounds
like a royalty I am Princess Toadstool
but I come in Prince
peach I I don't expect you to uh rule
country I expect you to dance on a
stripper pole yeah said it versus Pete
sounds like a stripper name
Wow that is so funny because I was gonna
say that I love Princess Peach so much
better like toadstool I think of fungus
and I think of like poisonous mushrooms
and I think of like little toad guys and
stool which means poop so come on how
could you possibly want a toadstool
I eat peaches I don't rescue them well
wait a minute but probably the weirdest
thing is Yoshi uh who we got to ride so
many times in Super Mario World and then
I'll be that dirty way uh he shows up in
the game after you've beaten the entire
game you have to get all 120 stars get
everything in the game before you can
find him on top of a castle and he talks
to you you don't ride him he gives you a
hundred lives and then he jumps off of
the castle he's at the top of the castle
gives you a hundred lives and it's like
well you have a clicker but I don't need
my one and just commit suicide how is
how is this fun for kids you just showed
you she committed suicide two different
games two completely different elements
but both have the same problem with me
which kind of can be commonly referred
to for me as crap on the back uh both
games feature the main character with
something on their back that for most of
the game you can't get rid of in Super
Mario Sunshine he's wearing this water
pack and he's like shooting water all
over the place or using water to pump up
higher and it's cute for a while but
it's on almost every single level it's
only small little bonus levels where you
don't get to wear it which are the best
parts of the game I want just a game of
that I don't need all of the water
levels and then Luigi's Mansion is the
same thing he just goes in the haunted
house and he's just sucking everything
up with a vacuum that you cannot get off
your back so you can't jump or anything
Wow's Andre it sounds like that would
suck see what I did there
hahaha that's why they pay me the big
bucks and buy big bucks I mean they just
laugh at me I actually bought this game
for my sister because she's got a we
down in Dallas and um they get us back
to the platform feel the scrolling
platform which is what made me feel
scared as a kid about Mario 64 but they
get back to the platform and you can
actually play two player it works out
better but I wouldn't know like are you
freaking kidding me or players at one
time you're welcome sister I Love New
Super Mario Bros Wii it's like it goes
back to the classic Mario platformers
that we all know and love and it's clear
that this is a popular title like it
still it came out last year and it's
still selling it sold more copies than
Super Mario Galaxy 2 which just came out
which got more accolades it just shows
that people love that classic 2d formula
so very few things to complain about I
think the only real problem that I have
um is that there's four players Mario
Luigi and in two tones it's like we have
the entire Nintendo library and you give
me a yellow toad and a blue toad and
this causes a lot of problems lately and
that screen gets pulled far back because
you're like which tone mi I don't know
who I am it gets really confusing this
is a point where I would have accepted
waluigi i would like alright we can have
Mario Luigi Wario and Waluigi I'll
accept it just don't give me a toad come
on the music is great the the flying
with different planets is great the
different types of levels and what you
can do in each of the levels it is
almost perfection there's only two words
that I can say that makes me annoyed at
Super Mario Galaxy 1 and 2 purple coins
any stage you have to do you've got to
collect purple coins to get your star
you will leave that game in frustration
you a lot a Wii Remote places where we
remote should not be you will be so
incredibly angry because they are just
mean literally literally the stage will
be like this you have to collect a
hundred purple coins in less than two
minutes on platforms that disappear and
reappear as you flip in the air and if
you get hit one time you're dead
go
what do you have a problem with me
Miyamoto get did I anger you too that
push you in a puddle or something as a
kid and don't remember it like you are
like apparently just mad at Americans
when you made these levels because they
are just evil evil purple stage level
they hate you but later on they got rid
of the purple coin mechanic like they
never did it again so he learned from
his mistakes so he did it again he did
it worse are you Andre
this is turning into a terrible birthday
party for Mario okay so what is it I
know what you're thinking Super Mario
Bros 3 best game of all time what could
possibly wrong with it well there is
something wrong with it and if you're a
younger gamer you probably wouldn't know
about it because you've been privileged
to get the this particular feature but
if you had the game originally you did
not have this certain feature but I'm
talking about
oh my video alright so if you guys want
to see that and the rest of this video
it's totally awesome in fact you're
entitled your entire channel is go over
there click here and here click on click
on Robert Pattinson space no just click
on his either
Oh